RUSSIAN INVASION.
IT'S ALL A MESS FOR DEMOCRATS IN
A MESS WITHOUT ANY CLEAR EASY
SOLUTION.
JENNA ME NOW FROM A WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AUTHOR OF THE NEW
BOOK SUPPRESSION, DECEPTION,
BIASED BY THE PRESS GET SO MUCH
LONG.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY OF THE SUBTLEST
AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
ALREADY.
I'M SEEING THIS AND I KNOW YOU
ARE AS WELL.
THERE IS AN UNMISTAKABLE SHIFT
IN THE MEDIAS TONE HERE, THEY
SEE THE ICEBERG AND IT'S THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
IT SEEMS LIKE THEIR BRAIN DOWN
THAT ICEBERG PRETTY FAST.
>> AND THE DANGER HERE FOR
JOE BIDEN AND ALL DEMOCRATS IN
THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE WHY A
LOT OF DISTRICTS THAT YOU
THOUGHT WERE TO BE SAFE
DEMOCRATS ARE TO BE IN PLAY THIS
NOVEMBER.
ALL OF THIS IS A SIGN OF HOW
DEPRESSED THE DEMOCRATS ARE.
AND WHAT HAPPENED IN THESE FIRST
MIDTERM ELECTIONS THE OPPOSITE
PARTY IS EXCITED THEY CAN'T WAIT
TO GO VOTE THE BUMS OUT OF
OFFICE AND THAT'S WHERE HOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE FEEL ABOUT
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT
EXCITED.
THEY NEVER REALLY WERE EXCITED
FOR JOE BIDEN TO BEGIN WITH.
IT'S GOING TO THE ALTERNATIVE
FOR DONALD TRUMP.
AND THEY'VE DONE SO POORLY AND
LIBERAL COLUMNISTS PILING UP
FURTHER DEPRESSES THE DEMOCRATIC
FACE LEADING TO NOVEMBER
ELECTION WHICH REPUBLICAN SURGE
IN TURNOUT AND THE DEMOCRATS
STAY HOME.
THAT COMPOUNDS ALL THE DEMOCRAT
PROBLEMS THAT'S WHY IT'LL LIKELY
BE A TSUNAMI IN NOVEMBER.
>> Laura: MOLLY I THINK THAT
THEY'RE GETTING NASTIER AS
THINGS ARE GETTING MORE
DESPERATE FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
SUMMING THAT NICOLE WALLACE SAID
WATCH.
>> I WORRY THAT IS POLITICS A
PARENTAL CHOICE.
ALL THE FOCUS IS ON HOW WELL IT
WORKS.
EVEN OUR CONVERSATION IT'S ABOUT
HOW WELL THEY'RE SERVING HIM.
THE TRUTH IS DEHUMANIZATION IS A
TACTIC FOR POLITICS, IT'S FOR
MORE.
THEY GET THEIR SOLDIERS TO TWO
CHILDREN IT'S BEING DEPLOYED IN
OUR POLITICS.
>> Laura: MOLLY, YOUR REACTION
TO THAT?
>> THAT ON RIDGED RANT, IT
REALLY IS.
ASSUMING SHE SHOULD REALLY
APOLOGIZE FOR.
AS THE TYPE OF RHETORIC THAT'S
REALLY UNACCEPTABLE.
BUT IT IS AN INDICATION AGAIN OF
WHAT WERE SEEING IN THE
SELECTION AT THIS TIME.
BECAUSE OF HOW MUCH THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY IS SORT OF MOVED
PRECIPITOUSLY TO THE LEFT AND
BECOME MUCH MORE ABNORMAL AND
ITS POLITICS AT ALLOWING
REPUBLICANS TO TAKE THIS MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF GROUND TO SORT OF THAT
80% OF THE COUNTRY THAT'S NORMAL
THAT DOESN'T THINK THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD TALK TO KIDS ABOUT OR
GENDER ISSUES WITHOUT PARENTAL
CONSENT.
IN TURNING THAT INTO A POLITICAL
ISSUE AND IT'S REALLY BROADLY
SUPPORTED BY MEMBERS OF VOTERS
IN BOTH PARTIES REALLY CUSTOM TO
WHAT ARI WAS TALKING ABOUT WITH
THE TROUBLE THE DEMOCRATS WERE
AND I NOVEMBER.
>> Laura: THERE IS A NEW BOOK
NEWS OF POTENTIAL BURNING
BERNIE.
>> I WAS CRITICAL DURING THE
HEIGHT OF COVID, BUT IF YOU
REALLY LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
FLORIDA ACTUALLY CAME OUT
ALL RIGHT.
>> AND THE ECONOMY IS STRONG.
>> Laura: ALMOST FELL OUT OF
MY CHAIR THERE ALREADY WAS LIKE
THEY'RE FINALLY GETTING IT.
THEY SEEM TO MANAGE THE
SITUATION PRETTY WELL.
>> SHE NEEDS TO BE CAREFUL SHE
SAID THEY CAN TO GET YOURSELF
CANCELED OR JOE BIDEN'S BUNNY
RABBIT IS GOING TO ATTACK HER.
[LAUGHS]
ONE OF THE BIG FACTORS GOING ON
ALL THESE ELECTIONS AND ALL THE
STATES IS THE REPUBLICANS IN RED
STATES BEEN TALKING COMMON SENSE
AND IT STARTED WHEN COVID BEGAN,
THE REPUBLICANS ARE MUCH MORE IN
TUNE WITH THE NEEDS OF THE
PEOPLE AND THERE'S ALSO LOOKING
BACK ON HOW SUCCESSFUL THINGS
WERE UNDER PRINT OUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HOW STRONG THE ECONOMY WAS,
CHILD POVERTY DROPPED, THE
EMPLOYMENT WAS SO LOW.
HOW WE WERE AT PEACE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THE DESTRUCTION OF ISIS.
ALTHOUGH SUCCESS IS TO CHECK ON
THE BORDER.
ALTHOUGH SUCCESSES HAS JUST BEEN
WASHED AWAY BY JOE BIDEN
REVERSING EVERYTHING THAT HE
COULD POSSIBLY DO REGARDLESS OF
THE CONSEQUENCES AND I STARTED
TO HEAR AT LEAST SOME PEOPLE
FRANKLY ACKNOWLEDGING HOW WELL
REPUBLICAN DOG GOVERNORS HAVE
DONE.
REPUBLICANS HAVE A GREAT THING
WAS SEEING EXAMPLES OF THAT
EVERY DAY.
>> Laura: MOLLY AT SEEMS LIKE
FROM NEW ENGLAND TO THE
SOUTHWEST TO THE MIDWEST
SOMETHING IS CHANGING.
I MEAN YOU FEEL IT IN HISPANIC
POLLING, YOU FEEL IT IN THE
POLLING OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
THEY MIGHT NOT OF LIKE SOME
THINGS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY THINK.
THEY KNOW THIS IS BAD.
THEY KNOW IT.
THERE'S NO SPINNING IT THAT
JOE BIDEN CARES OR HE FEELS YOUR
PAIN, HE WAS POOR ONCE, NONE OF
THAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
>> THIS IS IN A
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN PROBLEM BUT
OLD DEMOCRATIC PARTY PROBLEM
BECAUSE THEY DO CONTROL
EVERYTHING IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
THE PRESIDENCY, THE SENATE, THE
HOUSE.
MISSING IN THE STATES WERE
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS ARE
EXPERIMENTS AND WITH DIFFERENT
WAYS OF DOING THINGS CONTRARY TO
THE WEIGHT OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN DOING THINGS
MORE RECENT YEARS.
THESE ARE A LOT MORE POPULAR, HE
SAW THAT JUST LAST WEEK SAYING
THAT PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN'S
APPROVAL NUMBERS ARE JUST
TERRIFIC AMONG HISPANIC VOTERS.
WHAT WE SAW AND 2,020 YES,
REPUBLICANS DID POORLY IN THAT
ELECTION, BUT THEY HAD MORE
VOTERS THAN THEY'VE EVER HAD
BEFORE AND THEY CREATED THIS
BROAD MULTIRACIAL WORKING-CLASS
PARTY.
I THINK THAT'S GOT TO BE VERY
SOBERING FOR DEMOCRATS GOING
INTO THE NOVEMBER MIDTERMS, AND
TO THE 2,0